hey guys Dave and Anna we did a story on
alcohol we did a story on the media so
now let's do our third favorite thing
sex that's right in Chicago okay we are
gonna have sex right now you're not on
YouTube you're on xtube little did you
know sorry I mean we have to give them
what they want I know it's amazing so
many people think that we're having like
a secret relationship which by the way
we don't want David to find out about
that no no it would be bad if the guy
I'm sleeping with was here have you
let's talk about sex in Chicago they do
have sex there despite the cold
temperature Mayor Rahm Emanuel and the
board of EDD they are giving condoms
away at 24 chicago area schools high
schools and it's causing a lot of people
to be upset the people against sex
education blah blah it's the usual
argument that we hear all the time I for
one have no problem with kids getting
condoms and learning about sex because
then they probably won't do risky things
or at least you given them some mental
ammunition to not do risky things and if
they're gonna have sex they'll protect
themselves yeah all that stuff I think
you're on board that I remember well
actually I remember this one summer my
friend Lauren was walking through the
streets of weho the mean streets of weho
with me and there was like this truck
full of people handing out condoms and
like the second I got my my hand on that
condom I was like holy [ __ ] I need to
have sex right now like that's what
that's what it does right just seeing a
condom thinking about a condom touching
a condom you just immediately want to
have sex wow did that wave [ __ ] yeah
excited right now this x.x talk Oh
Emma's so yeah she's had a couple
litters so she's anxious from New
Orleans so she's been around the block
anything so so yeah oh you you dirty
game but I did a story is what happens
we did a story with her last week people
get addicted to the camera yes oh she's
there's a sign here she's like oh
get that excited about condoms but
anyway no making a serious point now
like you want to promote safe sex
teenagers are gonna have sex whether we
like it or not you got to educate them
about it you got to make sure that
they're protected that's the only way
that you're going to avoid teen
pregnancy and also STDs so all these
conservatives need to calm the hell down
why don't they pay attention to study
after study that proves that
comprehensive sex education is important
yeah and what is it about them that they
don't realize so you take sex education
away and you take contraception away and
then these kids are having sex then
they're young they don't have a lot of
money then they also say them you can't
have an abortion and they also say we
don't want to give assistance to people
that like it's this never-ending but
they just may view it in the frame of I
guess the Lord right this idea with the
Lord I mean you won't do they like to
take the religion and twist it in such a
way that meets their agenda and and the
reason why I say that is because if you
truly are a Christian and you truly
believe in the teachings of your Lord
Jesus Christ you know he was all about
helping people in poverty right helping
the needy and so it's strange to me that
you pick and choose which parts of your
religion you want to follow you want to
force people to have the babies but once
they need assistance you turn your back
away from them that goes against your
religion so you can't be hypocritical in
that way yeah well people keep asking me
if my boyfriend I are gonna have a kid
we say we're not sure but we're gonna
keep trying yep I